raconte interculturel de moyens c'est
une instance consultative de la ville de
montréal ça a été créé en 2003 ce que
nous faisons c'est demander conseils de
mme et ont des avis ou des
recommandations aux élus et au conseil
exécutif de la ville de montréal sur
toutes questions ayant trait aux
relations interculturelles et une
communauté d'origine diverse
donc pourquoi nous travaillons avec tous
les services de la ville de montréal que
ce soit la police les ressources
humaines la diversité sociale et cetera
la sécurité et nous travaillons depuis
2003 sur des sujets tels que l'équité en
emploi le profilage racial
le plan de développement urbain et lieux
de culte est toujours une mordue mais
qu'ils arrivent à la présidence la
présidence de ce comité tel culturelle à
montréal à montréal
tout d'abord on voit une annonce passée
pour faire pour être membre et il est en
moi j'avais envie de m'investir et ça
fait six ans que je suis en cinq ans je
pense que je suis autres enseignes et
l'année dernière des débuts donc on m'a
appelé pour me demander si je voulais
être la présidente avec la tribune j'ai
accepté ce que j'accepte bien c est
pourquoi j'en suis venu là en fait ce
conseil m'apporte plus que ce que je
leur apporte je pense parce que ça m'a
permis de découvrir le prendre
conscience de mes différentes identités
en croyant les autres on se sent plus
investi de ce que c'est la réalité des
gens qui vise à montréal de la chance
qu'on a d'être français martiniquais de
parler français en avivant avons rien
surtout et puis on prend conscience de
nos différentes identités qu'on est on
est à la fois français on est à la fois
compte y est et puis aussi on est quand
même bien martiniquais
montréalais québécois on prend
conscience votre identité là qui sont
vraiment dans tout ça il ya de la place
du vécu vanter nikkei fait monter
nicaise gens là-bas venons pays tant
traîné la patte du vécu martinique et la
place du vécu martiniquaise
c'est de rencontrer tous ses amis le
martinet qui collectent king je pense
que je serve de coûts souvent parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de plantes uniques et
qu'il s'installe de plus en plus je le
vois aussi des années ça fait quand même
dix sept ans que je vis à montréal et
j'ai jamais lâché le vécu manquait
justement comment vous dites je viens
ici trois quatre fois par année je suis
souvent ici j'ai besoin de ça pour me
ressourcer et c'est ça c'est le côté le
côté cette chaleur on a besoin de
retrouver et si cette chaleur en a qu'on
transmet complet 30 m aussi ce métissage
qu'on a en marre clinique et pour nous
c'est pas vraiment un problème est qu'on
retrouve là-bas qui est de plus en plus
présent et qu'on arrive plus facilement
intégré peut-être 17 ans de présence que
la ville de montréal s'est adapté à
cette diversité ethnoculturelle répétant
libellé dantesque montréal le vis bien
toutes ses composantes
il y avait des sécurités bien si vous
savez avec l'évolution là les relations
interculturelles c'est comme au niveau
mondial une évolution il ya une
évolution depuis le 11 septembre 2001 il
ya des problématiques qui reviennent
souvent
mais montréal s'y est investie puis
onglet de dollars dans un conseil c'est
qu'elle a envie que ça fonctionne elle a
envie que cette diversité là cette
richesse là puissent travailler ensemble
plus vivre enfants l envie que ça
fonctionne donc oui nous travaillons il
ya des choses à faire c'est pas facile
mais je pense qu'on est dans le bon de
l'autre non
bon pas et qu'on n'y arrive quand même
plusieurs projets sont sortis depuis
cinq ans notamment des projets sur le
travail sur la mobilité sur l'exclusion
sociale ça les chances d'aboutir bien
sûr que la descente habitées
dernièrement il ya eu on en sort bien ma
vie sur le profilage racial dernièrement
il ya une commission justement sur cette
problématique là et via des engagements
qui ont qui sont ou ont été pris qui
vont être mises en place
montréal est devenue il y à peine deux
mois une métropole donc elle est levée à
même de réfléchir à ce qu'elle fait de
sa diversité
elle est plus de possibilités que de
moyens et bien sûr plus de pouvoir elle
a obtenu à avoir pas il y a il y a eu un
musée mais un site internet mémoire
d'une immigration qui a été créée il ya
pas longtemps donc oui il ya des gestes
qui sont posées morial était à venise il
sanctuaire c'est le conseil qui avait
proposé kbc cette proposition là et le
maire a tout de suite accepté a réagi
très vite et on voit que c'était
nécessaire puisque depuis deux semaines
il ya une vague de réfugiés notamment
d'origine haïtienne qui arrivent à
montréal et ces gens là sont assez bien
en dehors de votre chance et vous avez
une part active au sud dans la société
en s'occupant des personnes
en fait je suis directrice adjointe d'un
centre d'éducation pour adultes qu'ils
attendent de la commission scolaire de
moyens et se sentent enfin moi je
m'occupe de 50 multiservices
donc nous demander qu à personne de
personnes en prison aux personnes en
formation à distance et moi je m'occupe
des services des personnes ayant des
besoins particuliers dans ces personnes
en vivent en situation de handicap et en
déficience intellectuelle
montez montez se situent ces partis le
constat fait soutirer ses parties de la
commission de scolaires de moyens donc
du ministère de l'éducation du québec
oui nous avons là encore nous avons de
plus en plus de personnes à dire
notamment qui arrivent à l'âge adulte
qui n'ont plus de lait services qu'ils
avaient quand il était en forme de lyre
et à 18 ans on y rit mais n'ont donc
nous offrons des services qu'ils
puissent continuer leurs études pour
qu'il puisse avancer dans la société
saint céré haut niveau au niveau
professionnel mais démenti les thèses
que vous êtes ou vous exciter les jeunes
de poids de l'eau de martinique arrive à
tenir à montréal venus faire leurs
études venir pourquoi pas prendre une
première orientation professionnelle
dans ce pays où était toujours
nécessaire d'aller ailleurs et puis de
voir de s'investir ailleurs de voir
comment ça se passe de prendre des reer
l'expérience bien sûr mais c'est
important si l'on veut venir chez soi de
faire progresser ce pays mais pour ça il
faut aller chercher des idées ailleurs
les vacances de noël